[Musik]
hallo schnauze jetzt gebe ich bin heute
euer vertretungslehrer frau und krätze
ist wieder schwanger war ist der henker
von wem ich weiß nicht wie auch
überhaupt thema heute das rentensystem
textaufgabe ein 25 jähriger ingenieur
zahl 42 jahre lang in die rentenkasse
ein
wie viel stunden täglich muss er als
rentner kommt flaschen sammeln um nicht
zu verhungern muss es sein ingenieur
jemand der mit seiner arbeit geld
verdient weil er in der schule
aufgepasst hat musst du dir nicht merken
hat sich noch keiner gedanken über die
rente gemacht wo rente wie
wahrscheinlich ist es dass ich so alt
wäre auch schön also leonie jacqueline
trinkt jeden tag vier dosen energydrinks
und rauch zwei schachteln kippen
wie wahrscheinlich ist es dass sie das
rentenalter erreicht aber nicht unser
thema die rente wird in deutschland seit
urzeiten durch den sogenannten
generationenvertrag regel täglich zu
meinte walter erst einmal 20 euro
gerne wieso danke ihr zahlt ich krieg
das geld nur wie scheiße ist das denn
wieso ich fahre jetzt noch ein paar
jahre meinen ford mustang und wenn ihr
euch einen leisten könnt ist das öl alle
win win situation also für mich jetzt
aber ortet der sorte aufkleber wir haben
die erde nur von unseren kindern
geliehen richtig und mit geliehenen
sachen geht man halt nicht so gut um wie
mit den eigenen ja wir haben den
planeten kaputt gemacht
so müsst ihr euch halt einen eigenen
suchen deshalb ist es wichtig zusätzlich
zur gesetzlichen rente privat
vorzusorgen mit einer riester oder rürup
rente
man kauft keine finanzprodukte die nach
spd politikern bekannt sind man geht ja
auch nicht in den rudolf scharping
sexshop man kann es euch trotteln nicht
oft genug sagen ihr kriegt keine rente
mehr eure generation ist die ist nochmal
der wissenschaftliche fachausdruck
ach ja perfekt ihr werdet gar keine
rente mehr kriegen wir werden in der
fußgängerzone gerettet wo ich mit den
tauben und brot kuchen prügeln
ihr werdet in ungarischen pflegeheimen
wohnen betreut von rumänischen pflegen
hast du dich eingebüßt das machst du im
alter auch wieder gewöhnlich daran
müsste halt selber kinder kriegen die
könnt ihr dann verraten wenn ihr alt
seid das ist der kreislauf des lebens so
kinder
das war's für heute hausaufgabe sucht
euch einen partner und versucht das
morden schwanger zu werden
nur bitte bitte nicht von malte
[Musik]